as the summer movie season draws to a
close Netflix is prepping a new batch of
originals that are just as good if not
better than anything you'll catch in the
theatres along with a lot of big time
movies and TV shows you might have
missed the first time around
stock up on popcorn because here's what
you can look forward to streaming on
Netflix in August wet hot American
summer ten years later grab your gear
and prepare for one more visit to camp
firewood most of the gang from the cult
classic wet hot American summer returns
for a sequel series that picks up in
1991 a decade after the events of the
original movie and the 2015 prequel
series the 8th episode wet hot American
summer ten years later we'll bring back
a lot of its originals as well as
introduce some new faces so get ready to
travel back in time to camp on August
4th
Voltron legendary defenders season 3 a
new take on the classic Voltron series
from the 80s legendary defender follows
the pilots of five mechanical lions who
unite to form the massive Voltron
but the 3rd season of this revival will
find our heroes in a tricky situation on
one hand they're still basking in the
glory of their victory over Emperor
Zarkon on the other his son Prince lotor
is ready to step into his villainous
shoes on top of all that the black
paladin Shiro is nowhere to be found
which means the other pilots can't form
Voltron no black lion no Voltron does
that mean Princess Allura could take on
a bigger role we'll find out when season
3 of Ultron premieres on August 4th
Ikaros if you haven't heard enough about
russia on the news lately you're in luck
Icarus is a documentary that will delve
into the story of how dozens of Russian
Olympians were caught in a state-run
doping program designed to ensure the
country would fare well at the 2014
Winter Games in Sochi the movie follows
filmmaker and biker Brian Fogle as he
attempts to beat anti-doping tests and
becomes mired in a conspiracy along the
way he befriends the man who runs
Russia's doping program dr. Gregory
watch Knopf who explains everything
behind the scenes including that some of
his colleagues have mysteriously
vanished the documentary which premiered
at the Sundance Film Festival in January
lands on Netflix on August 4th naked in
this romantic comedy marlon wayans finds
himself in his own version of Groundhog
Day but with a revealing new twist
instead of starting the day in bed he
continuously wakes up naked in an
elevator based on a Swedish film from
2000 the Americanized update will be
available to watch over and over
beginning August 11th a typical in this
quirky new Netflix series Jennifer Jason
Leigh stars as Elsa the protective
mother of Sam an autistic high school
senior who is navigating the transition
into adulthood
his journey isn't easy and it forces
both him and his mother to grapple with
change while Sam searches for love and
independence why does my doula say
remove steak from the mud atypical
premieres on the streaming service on
August 11th the defenders the top draw
of the month is the defenders the
long-awaited crossover miniseries that
ties together all four of Netflix's
Marvel shows the defenders will gather
Jessica Jones daredevil Luke Cage and
iron fists as the street-level heroes
team up against the diabolical villain
named Alexandra who may or may not be
the leader of the mysterious and ancient
organization known as the hand I'm not
hugging you the first season consists of
eight episodes all of which will be
available to stream August 18th so go
ahead and cancel all your plans for that
weekend this one will be a must watch
what happened to Monday if you're not
that interested in watching small screen
superheroes in action another option for
August 18th will be the premiere of what
happened to Monday this futuristic
thriller film centers on a family that
gives birth to septuplets in a world
where parents are only allowed to bear
one child each for all seven sisters to
survive the family will have to resort
to extraordinary measures the pic
features new Mira passes all seven of
the sisters each name for the day of the
week on which they're allowed to go
outside under a shared identity when one
of the sisters goes missing the others
must carefully comb the city for their
missing sibling before the government
gets their hands on her and exposes them
all this dystopian thriller appears to
fall somewhere in between TVs clone
drama orphan black and The Bourne
Identity movies so strap in for a wild
game of cat and mouse
well.ok mice def note what would you do
if you stumbled across a mysterious
notebook that allows you to kill anyone
you want just by writing their name in
it you probably shouldn't sell it on
Amazon based on the iconic manga series
that first debuted in 2003 the Netflix
original movie Death Note tells the
story of light Turner a Seattle High
School student who
to possess a notebook drop to earth by
ryu the god of death who handles all the
murdering shall we if he here turner
decides to use the notebook to become a
vigilante but his run might not last
long a detective named L is determined
to uncover the source behind the
killings Death Note premieres August
25th and from the looks of the trailer
it is definitely worth a watch
disjointed the new Netflix original
sitcom stars Kathy Bates as a lifelong
advocate for marijuana legalization who
finally lives out her dream as the owner
of a cannabis dispensary in Los Angeles
Chuck Lorre who brought the Big Bang
Theory and two and a Half Men to CBS
co-created the series with former Daily
Show head writer David Jabbar Baum so
prepare to find yourself in a cloud of
small screen smoke starting on August
25th new movies Netflix is exponentially
increasing its Keanu factor in August
with all three installments of the
Matrix trilogy hitting the service on
August 1st but if you're in the mood for
action with a little less social
commentary you can watch Will Smith
battle a giant mechanical spider in wild
wild west that same day for those who
love drama the founder is a must watch
it stars Michael Keaton as McDonald's
creator Ray Kroc in this captivating
biopic that hits Netflix on August 2nd
Netflix will also add gold the recent
crime drama starring a very bald Matthew
McConaughey on August 16th if you're
looking for something a little more
highbrow however the documentary drop is
pretty solid for the month as well the
critically acclaimed barbecue which is
about barbecue culture in different
countries comes online August 15th and
feel rich health is the new wealth from
executive producer Quincy Jones centers
on a revolutionary shift in hip-hop
culture from overindulgence to
maintaining a healthier lifestyle and
will be available August 23rd more
vintage new releases for the month
include Jackie Brown and I am Sam while
more recent little scene films like
Cloud Atlas and beautiful creatures will
also be available for your streaming
pleasure this month as for those with
kiddos not to worry there will be plenty
of new family-friendly fodder available
in August as well including sing holes
and a Cinderella story after the little
ones go to bed though be sure to check
out the newest thriller options on the
site including the astronauts wife funny
games in the number 23
all of which arrive on August 1st new
television as always there's a new batch
of TV shows to catch up with or suddenly
become addicted to in August if you
haven't gotten enough of the Medellin
drug cartel thanks to narcos the first
season of surviving Escobar's will
launch on the first of the month
meanwhile the sixth season of ABC's once
upon a time will drop on August 25th
helping catch you up on all the
Storybrooke shenanigans before the
seventh season reboots the show into
unknown magical territory this fall
trust me I've done you a favor all magic
comes with a price and if you didn't
catch the first season of NBC's hit new
sitcom the good place well somebody
royally [ __ ] up be sure to Circle
August 25th on your calendar because
it's well worth your time you have a
second to eat my farts thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to